It is Thursday, which means we have the latest
jobs numbers and they're not good when we
add the jobs lost in the last week or last
week, I guess I would say that puts the total
number of jobs lost during the seven weeks
of what we would, I guess call the Corona
virus.
Quarantine's at thirty three and a half million
jobs last week.
The latest numbers, about 3.2 million more
people lost their jobs and filed for unemployment.
Now, if you are looking at these numbers and
you are determined to find some okay news
or some sign of it's not as bad as it could
be, what you could say and you would be right
to say it is that each day I'm sorry, each
week fewer people are losing their jobs.
We had more than 6 million people lose their
jobs in the first in
the last week of March.
The first week of April, only about half of
that number.
Each week over the last couple of weeks have
lost their jobs in the 3 million job range.
But in total, these are unconscionable numbers.
Now, to give you a little bit of context before
this all started.
So seven weeks ago, eight weeks ago, the U.S.
workforce was believed to be about one hundred
and fifty eight million people.
Hundred and fifty eight million people were
formerly in the workforce in the United States
before this all started.
So when you look at 33 and a half million
jobs.
That is 21 percent of the labor force of the
United States that has lost their jobs, not
in a year, which would be a tragedy in seven
weeks.
In seven weeks.
If three months ago somebody had said in the
next three months,
one out of five Americans who is working is
going to lose their job.
No one no one would have believed it.
But if you force their hand to say, how do
you think the stock market would be doing?
How do you think all these if they would say,
well, it would be absolute, complete devastation,
but nobody would have believed that that is
how bad things could possibly get in such
a short period of time.
But we are there now, previously before this
phase, before coronavirus.
The largest one week job loss.
New unemployment claims was somewhere in the
600000 range, maybe close to 700000.
We have done five to 10 times those numbers,
not in total during coronavirus each week
during the last seven weeks.
And again, the total number is now.
Thirty three and a half million jobs lost.
Now, there are people who are
seeing these numbers and they're in the camp
of open it.
All right.
Now, no matter what, to save the economy right
there, they're in that camp.
And those folks see these numbers and they
say, here's the evidence, here's the evidence
that we must reopen everything right now regardless
of the human cost.
And by the way, the human cost is really big
anyway with things shut down, which is true.
And that tells us just how contagious corona
viruses.
That's a very short sighted perspective.
It's not a good idea.
But I do believe that there are things that
we can glean from these numbers that should
inform what should have been done and also
how things should be handled going forward.
First of all, even economies that appear to
be doing well, Trump has called the economy
up until seven weeks ago, the best economy
in the
history of any country ever.
I don't call it that, but there's no doubt
that what we had up until seven weeks ago
was an economy that by the normal metrics
we use unemployment, inflation, consumer confidence,
stock market, all of those measures, it was
doing well.
It was an economy that was doing well.
But what we learned is even those economies
are extremely fragile.
Even those economies can, on the drop of a
dime, make 180 degree turn.
This fragility is inherent to our economy,
in part because of the marginal nature of
a lot of the work in the economy, in part
because of the low savings rate, which is
fueled by stagnant wages over a long period
of time.
Dramatic inequality also gives you averages
that seem OK, even when a lot of individuals
are in a very precarious, precarious financial
state.
The just in time
nature of many of our industries and supply
chains, all of these things should confirm
to us that even when the economy looks pretty
good by the standard met metrics, it's a very
fragile economy that we have.
That's part of the system.
That's a feature of it, not a bug.
Number two, what we also need to think about
is if you look at other countries right now,
if you look at Italy, France, Spain, a lot
of these hubs of cases, South Korea, of course,
they are all on the dramatic decline.
They are doing really, really well while we
are still having twenty five hundred deaths
a day.
And that leads me to have to talk about Donald
Trump's failure here.
Now, I'm not going to do this completely irrational
thing where I could sit here and tell you
Trump, obviously.
Have shut everything down on February
20th when we had 15 cases.
Trump was very dumb and wrong to say on February
around, you know, late February we have 15
cases and it'll soon be zero.
That was a dumb thing to say.
No president is going to shut down a country
with 15 cases.
I'm not going to sit here and tell you that
that's the logical thing that should have
been done at the time.
But don't look at February 20th, look at March
5th, look at March 10th, OK?
On March 5th, we had 221 cases here in the
United States.
On March 5th, China had 80000 cases proving
that this could go very, very big.
But importantly.
Italy had 4000 cases on March 5th.
So on March 5th, we knew 15 cases weren't
going to zero.
We went to 21.
We knew that a country could have close to
100000 cases.
And we knew that another country could have
the disease seeded and already have 4000 cases.
That's what we knew from Italy.
So March 5th would not have been a crazy time
to say, hey, governors, all 50 of you, we
need to stay at home starting now.
If we had done that on March 5th, I'm not
saying February 20th.
But if we had done it on March 5th, we would
now have done 60 days of it and we would have
had economic impacts similar to what we've
had.
But we would be in very good shape right now
compared to where we are.
By mid March, when the sporadic stay at home
orders started in some states but not others,
the US had already been seeded with close
to 4000 cases of Corona virus.
It was too late then to really stop the spread.
It was especially not going to happen when
only some states started stay at home orders
in the middle of March.
So don't fall for the trumpets talking point
that there were no cases in February and so
it would have been crazy to shut it down then
they are right.
I don't know of any president that with 15
cases would have demanded or asked 50 governors
to shut things down.
But by early March, March 5, March 7, look
at the numbers for yourselves.
We had the data that we needed to take it
seriously and Trump did not at that point
in time.
He'll brag.
He shut down travel from China.
But but clearly at that point, it had gone
outside of China
to a significant degree.
And we now have 33 million jobs lost.
But because of this rolling patchwork of shutdowns
in some states and not in others, we see some
states improving, some worsening.
We still have twenty five hundred deaths a
day.
And FEMA and the CDC believe it is possible
that by June 1st, we will actually be up to
three thousand deaths every single day.
It's been mishandled.
Let's be accurate in our criticism of how
it's been mishandled, but it has been dramatically
mishandled.
And not only are we seeing a human toll.
We are also seeing an optional economic toll.
We were going to have an economic impact,
but we could have grinned and buried it for
60 days starting March 5th, and we would be
in much better shape right now.